hello believe nation my name is Evan
Carmichael my one word is believe and I
believe that entrepreneurs are going to
solve all the major problems of the
world going to help you on your journey
today we're going to talk about seven
ways to get your clients on board with
value-based pricing and as always guys
as you're listening if you hear
something that really resonates with you
please leave it down the comments below
put quotes around it to other people can
be inspired as well and when you write
it down it's much more likely to stick
with yourself to enjoy so color problem
with a lot of entrepreneurs is they're
not getting the money they deserve to
get for the values of the putting out
and they have a hard time one charge you
want their worth which could be a topic
for a whole other video but to getting
the clients are the right fits with them
who understand the value and are willing
to pay them for it and so today I'm
going to share with you my seven ways
and how to get your clients aboard with
value-based pricing my number one
strategy is don't I don't try to
convince my clients of anything it's
very rare to find clients who start with
you at a really small level and are
willing to grow with you and pay you
more and more and more and more it can
happen but it's very rare this is why
selling to entrepreneurs is usually a
really terrible idea
because I love entrepreneurs and it's a
rough business model for most people
because entrepreneurs don't have money
as much as you may love the cause and
the business and everything that they're
up to they don't have the money to be
able to pay you for what you do and even
if they do value it they value your
experience and expertise they don't
actually have the money to pay you for
it there'll be other people who have the
money but they don't value what you do
enough and so those aren't ideal clients
either and instead of wasting your
energy trying to convince people to
spend more money with you or that you
can provide the value I would rather
invest my time prospecting and working
with ideal clients and so I don't really
try to bring clients aboard with
value-based price
I try to go out and find the clients
that are early attuned to it and work
with those people instead so that takes
us to step two which is define what an
ideal client looks like so one that had
to have the budget right whatever range
you're in so for example when I deal
with brand my first brand deal was for
$500 $500 to write a blog post and I
ended up over delivering doing great
work for them and this is a great
example of I carried them so far right
so I started with $500 and then we moved
it to 750 or something than 1000 and
then 1215 and 1500 and I moved them from
500 to 1500 dollars for each post that I
was doing but that was their cap that
was their limit and I was bringing them
more than $1,500 worth of value every
time I did it because I put in so much
work and effort and so eventually I had
to leave them instead of trying to bring
that brand with me up I left them and I
brought on bigger brand deals and so
understand what is an ideal client what
do they look like for you what budget do
they need to have what values did need
to have right if you understand your one
word and you understand what values they
are they're looking for having a good
mash most of the brands that want to
work with me I say no to because we're
not in alignment because they just want
to sell you guys stuff because they
don't actually care much about
entrepreneurs so if you don't believe in
entrepreneurs you're not going to be a
good fit for this channel I don't want
to do a deal with you if you throw tons
of cash on me because it's not going to
be a good long-term fit which is going
to fight because of values differences
and to understanding the clients I have
the budget constant have the values
clients doing the work that is
meaningful important to you setting that
list of what an ideal client looks like
for you being able to identify them will
help you be able to grow and get them on
board tip number three is prove your
value and so once you've found who these
ideal targets are you've created your
criteria and you've identified who these
people are with these brands our
companies are I love starting off with a
small deal and then finding a way to
make it bigger prove your value nobody
knows who you are you don't have a name
you don't have a reputation you look
like everybody else prove
or value if you get in a low price with
the low amount of work right like some
small project then it's easier to get a
yes and it's easier to continue on with
them and so understand that whatever it
is that you do a company you want to
work with they probably already have
some kind of existing supplier they're
already working with people who look
like you then working with your
competition in some respect and so if
you go in and try to pitch tick you're
on this huge deal one it involves
kicking out your competition who they
have an established working relationship
with and a big deal involves more people
at that company to make a decision and
so the bigger it is more complicated it
is the more steps involved the less
likely you are to get a yes what I'd
rather do is go into a company and ask
where they're unhappy find one small
scenario where they are unhappy so if
you're doing website design as an
example instead of trying to take over
an entire company's website find one
landing page like what one landing page
are you unhappy with just give me one
thing that you're unhappy with your
current supplier is not doing a good job
with for whatever reason no judgment
against them but you're just not happy
with let me prove my value to you and
charge them a reasonable price to do one
small project something that it's easy
for them to give to you that one person
has to make a decision on and you got
your budget to work with even though
it's a small one and then over deliver
like crazy give them so much value be
their favorite supplier be the person
that then whoever you work with saying
these kinds of such great work we should
give them more business if you do that
work you won't even have to pitch the
other business getting the whole website
because they're going to be fighting for
you to have that business so it makes
sense the more entrenched you are the
more value you're providing the tighter
you build that relationship giving them
so much more value than the competition
is they're going to fight to give you
more and work because they love working
with you and so too often people come in
and they pitch these huge ideas when
nobody knows who they are and it's just
so complicated that the yell takes too
many steps that you're not going to get
a yes if you go with some easy to say
yes to decision and then you over
deliver like crazy you're going to get
more and more and more work but make
sure it's with an ideal client
[Music]
tip number four is figure out the why of
your customers this is super important
in a competitive world where a lot of
people are trying to underprice each
other the ultimate way to win over your
customers is by understanding why
they're coming to you in the first place
so here's what happens at our school
whenever clients come in to TDS one of
the first questions they ask is how much
of the classes what I make sure to do is
ask them why they interested before we
even talk about pricing if I can figure
out their why whether to make friends to
be more comfortable with their body
whatever it is I can tailor my
conversation around that and what
happens then is price doesn't become as
important because ultimately people will
pay a lot more for product that
addresses their needs their deep down
desires so if you spend a couple extra
minutes to figure out the why of your
customers you'll be able to charge them
with your worth and ultimately have
loyal customers number five is over
deliver like crazy and I touched on it
in point number three it's really
important that once you get in the door
that you are doing everything you can to
be remembered and just providing so much
insane value to help them and what you
want to think about is what skills do I
have what people do I know that can help
make this project just so much better
it's an example of things that I've done
in that first blog post that I had $500
for my very first brand deal all they
wanted was 300 words you know for a blog
post that they're going to post on their
site and so I didn't just write 300
words and give them content I wrote 1500
words something like that and I give him
the longest article that they ever had
for their blog I made a video that was
custom for that post I promoted it to my
newsletter list and let my audience know
to go check it out and they hired me and
they hired none other influencers so
there's ten of us total for this project
and I was the only one that they picked
to continue on with why because my
content got more impact got more results
more engagement more views and all of
the other nine combines because I gave
them so much more value and so anytime a
customer
asking for this you want to give them
this but then you also want to give them
more right using your skills your
resources your connections your
knowledge to give them more than what
they asked for that's how you over
deliver that's how you can start raising
your prices that's how you can start
getting more business within the
organization and so maybe you know
somebody that can help that company
maybe you can connect to people together
to companies together where there's an
interaction is mutually beneficial maybe
you can provide a video or go along or
write like always think about the
baker's dozen thirteen is the baker's
dozen so you get you by twelve or
something you get to 13th one for free
what can you add in that is unexpected
value for them helps them in any way
possible cover them on your website be a
testimonial for them on LinkedIn now
whatever it is showcase their stuff
follow them on Twitter and retweet their
things and be engaged because I
guarantee you no other supplier they're
working with is doing this and this is
your chance to stand out you get some
small easy to say yes to deal and you
provide just so much value to them that
they want to find ways they will fight
for ways to continue working with you
[Music]
tip number six is keep increasing your
pricing so I'm a big fan as you get
better as you understand how to add more
value as you improve your skill sets and
you can bring more value to the table
that you continue to increase your
pricing so the way I do it on my youtube
channel is an example so you guys are
watching is I can only work with so many
brands at a time unusual work on annual
deals so the brain works with meal for B
for at least a year and so because I can
only work with so many brands at a time
every time I get a new brand I increase
the price all right this limited supply
we can only do so many and so okay for
you is this and now next time with this
next time what's this and it's the same
thing before I was doing YouTube when I
was just having my website and my blog
and my newsletter list you know I would
send one newsletter out a week maximum
that would be in partnership with a
brand so there's only four months that
could happen and so I'd sell the first
one at $1500 the second one maybe $1,500
now myspace is getting limited
okay the next one's that 1750 in the
next ones at 2000 and if somebody falls
off the next one's going to be at 2250
because your supply goes down
right we start increasing your prices as
your value goes up as you know more you
can bring more to your clients you start
increasing your prices or a lot of times
entrepreneurs just stay stuck in the
same zone and for like many years
charging the same price even though
they're bringing way way way more value
so as you bring more value you start
raising your prices alongside it and tip
number seven this is one of my favorite
is to be a thought leader if you are so
great at what you do showcase your
expertise be a thought leader so that
people will find you so that you are not
out having to do cold emails or cold
tweets or cold calls or go to go to
events and congresses
and conventions to try to make
connections be a thought leader to have
people find you see when people hire
thought leaders they're willing to pay
more if they're bringing on somebody who
they think is the expert at this field
they're going to be willing to pay more
they are seeking you out because you are
the leader if someone is only going to
hire somebody based on price they're not
going to look at who's speaking in these
events right who's writing the white
papers who's being interviewed on the
different YouTube channels just a
different mindset the people who want
the value the people who want fast
results of people who appreciate the
people who are bringing those results to
them they seek those people out and they
pay premium dollars for those people so
the way to get that is to expose
yourself be a thought leader share your
opinions share your expertise anytime a
reporter is talking about a subject that
is in your field write to them and give
your opinion share your expertise you
could be a resource for them right
reporters are always looking for people
to comment on articles they always need
industry expertise that could be you
that's how I got into New York Times and
all these other publications and all
these lists of speakers and thought
leaders and SEO and experts and social
media experts to follow because I did a
lot of work connecting with reporters
put out great content start a YouTube
channel B start a Twitter account you
know whatever it is that your expertise
is you've got to write you rather make
video you rather do audio you need to
spend time being a media company
and sharing your expertise to be seen as
a thought leader so that people will
find you and you could start turning
people down when I look at brand deals
these platforms out there where you can
bid on working with a brand right
famebit is one as an example
brands opposed to DLC we have you know a
thousand dollars to work on the field
and all of these different creators will
bid on it you have no leverage in that
situation you're one of hundreds of
graders bidding on a project and it's
just a race to the bottom I'm willing to
do this for this I'm willing to throw in
this for free you compete against so
many people and the brand has all the
power where when I'm creating content
and the brand's come to me I'm the one
who has the power I'm the one who could
set the pricing I'm the one who could
dictate the terms because they're coming
to me and so that's what I want to
create for you I want people to come to
you to find you to reach out to you
because you are the thought leader
expert in the field and you change that
you already know it like if you're an
entrepreneur you should be good at what
you do you really have the knowledge but
you're only helping to select with the
people or if you're making it more
public and you're share with your inside
here out there you're going to attract
people who value that expertise or pay
you top dollar for it so those are my
seven tips seven ways and how to get
clients aboard with value-based pricing
I'd love to know what do you guys love
about this video what was the biggest
takeaway for you is there an 8 9 10 that
you want to add to the list leave it
down in the comments below I'm super
curious to find out I also want to thank
Miss oval for asking for this topic I
made this video because of him and his
request if you guys have a request that
you like me to make a feature 7 wins
video on check the link in the
description and go and cast your vote I
also want to give a quick shout to katie
cruise katie thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book your one
word and making that video on your
YouTube channel I really really really
appreciate it and I'm so glad that you
enjoyed the book so thank you guys for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you soon